[Musique]
nous devons changer le regard l'autre
n'est pas quelqu'un de gauche
notre taille est quelqu'un qui a la même
capacité commandes de réfléchir au
problème qui se pose c'est accepter que
déjà très très différents ne s'en rend
pas compte qu'ils ont beaucoup de choses
qui me plaît c'est un homme de terrain
il a bien compris et de l'autre côté les
problèmes que les salariés pouvez
rechercher les gens rejoignent
il y à ce qui peut changer mais les
français les promesses mirobolantes ne
s'aperçoit pas on ne les écoute pas on
ne l'est pas
il est franc et intelligente et idée
finalement à faire des mécontents de
voir les impôts rester comme il est à
dire non
après c'est bien et c'est quelque chose
de tabou quand toujours s'intéresser aux
gens que je voudrais vous dire les trois
directions qui me paraissent et les
trois directions vont dans le même sens
que chacun d'entre nous comme territoire
français nous ayons un vrai qu'on trouve
et il ne devrait pas première direction
qu'il y ait des engagements en petit
monde mais majeur avec détails
d'organisation précise et vérifiée
je ne les écoute
deuxièmement que pour tout ce qui
concerne notre vie de tous les jours le
pouvoir reproche qu'on puisse saisir et
d'interpeller les choses pas et qu'ils
doivent rendre des comptes
troisième
reste à la mondialisation il faut une
vraie europe qui piste pour descendre et
aussi pour tout ce qui touche au 4ème
non pas seulement par des idéologies
mais par des valeurs là pas de questions
plus importantes
la médiation bras ce qui leur manque
on leur parle pas je pense les censeurs
de la cité saturne été et seront
certainement et je pense que c'est
quelqu'un aussi qu'il ya beaucoup
d'humour ce quelqu'un d'autre et la
lutte contre l'illettrisme haïti le
secours des combats il a fait très tôt
partie 2
de tous les comités de soutien il s'est
engagé auprès de tous ceux qui
fréquentaient maîtrise et la ferme tout
en étant la chance à tour ces cas là
n'oublie engagements pris et va sculpter
pouvoir proches et des valeurs on peut
avoir le sentiment et ça commence le
matin
[Musique]
ma conviction profonde est celle ci
notre mission est de rendre au peuple
français
un bien précieux un bien unique qui l'a
perdu de vue depuis longtemps et qui
porte un nom tout simple
ça s'appelle l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
un jour quelqu'un est venu me voir et
m'a dit le président de la république
monsieur c'est celui à qui on confie les
clés de la maison
alors j'ai besoin de savoir qui vous
êtes j'ai trouvé que c'était une
remarque juste
je m'appelle françois bayrou j'ai 55 ans
je suis né dans un petit village des
pyrénées qui s'appelle bordères dans une
famille de paysans la vie a fait que j
habite toujours encore aujourd'hui je
suis allé à l'école communale
c'était l'école républicaine je laime
parce qu'elle offrait sa chance à tous
quel que soit leur milieu
puis ils sont venus les années lycée
j'ai passé le bac en 68 puis
l'université à bordeaux jusqu'à
l'agrégation de lettres français latin
grec
j'attache beaucoup d'importance à cette
culture classique qui est un peu de la
culture française et puis la vie vient
avec ses joies et ses peines
et elle bouleverse tous un jour mon père
est mort dans un accident du travail
j'ai décidé avec ma mère de prendre sa
suite
j'ai travailler de mes mains et c'est
une fierté pour moi
en même temps j'ai été professeur un
jeune professeur et j'ai beaucoup aimé
transmettre ce que je savais ma femme
s'appelle elisabeth nous nous sommes
mariés nous avions vingt ans il y à 35
ans aujourd'hui nous avons eu six
enfants quatre filles et deux garçons
très tôt la politique est entré dans ma
vie j'ai été un jeune député un jeune
ministre avec passion j'ai travaillé
j'ai observé j'ai eu raison je me suis
trompé j'ai appris voilà qui je suis et
maintenant ce que je veux faire je veux
rassembler les français
jamais notre pays n'a eu devant lui un
tel défi jamais il n'a connu en même
temps le chômage qui ne recule pas la
dette que nos enfants devront rembourser
les banlieues fracturée
doute sur l'école le doute dans les
usines plus la crise du climat plus les
menaces sur les retraites plus les fins
de mois difficiles pour les petits
revenus aussi bien que pour les classes
moyennes
et tout cela avec en toile de fond
l'immense mouvement de la mondialisation
en face de tout cela la vieille guerre
politique un camp contre l'autre ce
n'est plus la question pour moi je peux
discuter et travailler avec des gens
compétents de tous bords je peux
travailler avec des gens qui ne pensent
pas exactement comme moi je le peux et
je le veux chez des objectifs simples
je veux que tous les enfants sachent
lire et écrire avant d'entrer en 6e
je propose qu'on y arrive en cinq ans je
garantirai les moyens nécessaires je
veux stopper l'augmentation de la dette
je propose qu'on le fasse en trois ans
je veux que l'on crée des emplois de
vrais emplois
je propose qu'on permette à toutes les
entreprises françaises de créer deux
emplois nouveaux
sans avoir à payer de charges pendant
cinq ans je veux sortir les rmistes de
leur isolement
je leur proposerai une activité
rémunérée dans la société dans des
associations collectivités locales je
veux rendre du pouvoir d'achat à ceux
qui travaillent et aussi à ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie
je proposerai que les petites retraites
et le minimum vieillesse soit portée à
90 % du smic en cinq ans je veux
relancer l'ascenseur social et que tout
le monde puisse avoir sa chance
d'arriver en haut
même en partant d'en bas je veux que la
france soit à l'avant-garde de la lutte
pour la biodiversité et contre le
réchauffement de la planète et je veux
réconcilier les français avec l'europe
et l'europe avec la france
ces objectifs là je ne sais pas s'ils
appartiennent à un bord ou à l'autre ce
que je sais c'est qu'ils sont urgents
veut qu'on avance et c'est maintenant je
vous propose d'être le président qui
rassemble les français pour reconstruire
la france
ma conviction profonde est celle ci
notre mission est de rendre au peuple
français
un bien précieux un bien unique qui l'a
perdu de vue depuis longtemps et qui
porte un nom tout simple
ça s'appelle l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes chers concitoyens l'élection
présidentielle c'est un moment clé
c'est un moment formidable en réalité
parce que c'est celui où un peuple tout
entier décide du chemin qu'il va suivre
ce peuple c'est vous et je suis venu
vous dire une chose très simple nous les
citoyens français nous le peuple
français
nous avons les moyens de nous en sortir
nous pouvons nous en sortir
[Musique]
il faut concentrer nos efforts tous les
efforts de la nation tous les efforts du
pays sur des priorités soigneusement
choisis je vous propose d'abord de
recréer des emplois des emplois pour les
jeunes qui manquent de temps pour les
adultes qui ont charge de famille
retrouvé de l'emploi c'est choisir un
mot d'ordre c'est produire chez nous
produire en france et consommer français
pour soutenir la production du pays
deuxième priorité nous devons
désendetter la france
personne n'en parle dans cette campagne
électorale est cependant le
surendettement d'un pays est aussi grave
que le surendettement d'une famille
alors bien sûr il y aura des économies à
faire
mais il ya tant de gaspillage autant de
mauvaise organisation que ces économies
nous pourrons les trouver sans porter
atteinte aux services qu'on doit rendre
aux français et à leurs familles
troisième choix nous devons retrouver
l'éducation nationale qui faisait la
fierté de notre pays
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
décisions il ya beaucoup de réformes à
faire mais j'en propose une que tout le
monde comprendra tous les enfants quel
que soit leur milieu d'origine que tous
ces enfants maîtrisent la lecture
l'écriture le calcul et même l'amour de
la langue française
alors nous leur offrirons la clé de
toutes les réussites ultérieure
et puis quatrième impératif sans
confiance ya pas de redressement
la confiance ça passe par
l'établissement de règles nouvelles et
simple qui sont celles de tous les
grands pays du monde et que nous avons
perdus de vue il ya longtemps
pour ça il faut des décisions très
simple il faut que l'on mette un terme
au cumul des mandats il faut que les
parlementaires soient désormais présents
à l'assemblée nationale et vote en
personne et que les votes soient
publiques
il faut qu'on reconnaisse le vote blanc
ses quatre priorités produire et
consommer en france désendetter le pays
retrouver la meilleure éducation du
monde et moraliser la vie publique pour
que nous en soyons fiers c'est le chemin
du redressement que notre pays attend et
c'est le seul moyen de lui rendre ce mot
qui lui manque depuis si longtemps
le mot espoir
[Musique]